foreign
what's your name I'm Freud what's your
title uh I'm gonna let somebody
technician on the right seat for the
next car in one sentence explain what
you do uh everything Electronics on the
car have you ever messed up
the little things here and there maybe
it is high pressure and you've got two
three seconds to do a wheel change
during a full crew Pit Stop have you
ever been scared not really did you go
to university no I did like an
apprenticeship so I learned in the job
at a different theme what's the hardest
part of your job
um let me stay on top of being healthy
and
so getting enough sleep what's the
happiest moment of your job
I think when Mick got his first points a
few races back what has been your
longest day on the job hours uh probably
Barcelona testing maybe 2019 so it was
25 hours I think we did straight do you
ever get angry a little bit I can be a
bit stubborn at times what do you do in
your free time I like riding motorbikes
you had to work for one other sport what
would it be
it's probably not a GP and how badly do
you want to win
I didn't want to bend badly